>>> SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM WILL
HAVE TO TESTIFY IN A GEORGIA
PROBE INVESTIGATING EFFORTS TO
OVERTURN THE 2020 ELECTION.
THE SUPREME COURT DENIED HIS
REQUEST TO BLOCK THE SUBPOENA.
HE ARGUED THE SPEECH OR DEBATE
CLAUSE SHIELDED HIM FROM
TESTIFYING.
TWO YEARS AGO THE GEORGIA
SECRETARY OF STATE TOLD THE
"WASHINGTON POST" THAT GRAHAM
APPEARED TO SUGGEST HE TOSSED
LEGALLY CAST BALLOTS.
QUOTE, IT SURE LOOKED LIKE HE
WAS WANTING TO GO DOWN THAT
ROAD.
GRAHAM CALLED THAT RIDICULOUS.
JOINING ME, CNN CONTRIBUTOR,
FORMER WHITE HOUSE COUNSELLOR.
SO SENATOR GRAHAM'S OFFICE
CALLING THIS A WIN FOR HIM
SAYING THE COURT AFFIRMED THE
CLAUSE COULD APPLY IN CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS?
>> IT'S NOT A WIN FOR LINDY
GRAHAM.
IT IS A LOSS ON BALANCE FOR
LINDSEY GRAHAM.
HE ARGUED THAT HE WAS EXCEPT
FROM TESTIFYING.
HE DIDN'T HAVE TO TESTIFY AT ALL
UNDER THE SPEECH AND DEBATE
CLAUSE WHICH IS PART OF THE
CONSTITUTION WHICH SAYS A
SITTING MEMBER OF CONGRESS CAN'T
BE FORCED TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
OUTSIDE OF CONGRESS.
THE PROBLEM IS THE FEDERAL
COURTS, UP TO AND INCLUDING THE
SUPREME COURT SAID YES, HOWEVER,
THAT ONLY APPLIES TO YOUR
LEGITIMATE LEGISLATIVE
ACTIVITIES.
ANYTHING YOU WERE DOING WITH THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN, ANY EFFORTS TO
INTERFERE WITH THE ELECTION, TO
PRESSURE STATE OFFICIALS.
THAT'S ALL FAIR GAME.
BOTTOM LINE, HE HAS TO GO IN
FRONT OF THE GRAND JURY.
TAKE AN OATH AND ANSWER
QUESTIONS FROM THE PROSECUTOR.
>> AND IF HE INVOKES THE CLAUSE
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS ABOUT HIS
POST 2020 ELECTION ACTIVITIES,
WOULD IT MEET THE BAR AND MANY
PEOPLE MAY NOT KNOWN WHAT THAT
CLAUSE WAS INTENDED TO BE USED
FOR.
>> IT IS A NEW CLAUSE TO MOTION
THE COURTS.
AT THE DON'T ADDRESS IT VERY
OFTEN.
SO YES, HE CAN RAISE IT AND HIDE
BEHIND IT FOR A WHILE.
THE HIGH COURT, AS WELL AS THE
LOWER COURTS, HAVE GOTTEN
THEMSELVES FAMILIAR WITH THIS
CLAUSE.
AND IT IS PRETTY LIMITED.
IT IS LIMITED TO LEGISLATIVE
ACTIVITIES, AS ELIE SAID.
>> IF THE SENATOR OBJECTS TO A
QUESTION DURING TESTIMONY, HOW
DOES THAT GET DECIDED?
>> SO THIS IS THE PROBLEM.
THE SUPREME COURT SAID, IF THERE
IS A DISPUTE ABOUT A QUESTION,
YOU CAN GO BACK TO THE DISTRICT
COURT, THE FEDERAL TRIAL COURT.
I GUARANTEE YOU HE'S LOOKING AT
THE CALENDAR THINKING, THERE
WILL BE A NEW CONGRESS EARLY
2023.
IF HE CAN THROW ENOUGH ISSUES UP
IN DISPUTE, THE STRATEGY MAY BE
TO STRETCH THIS OUT UNTIL THE
NEW CONGRESS TAKES OVER.
I'M SURE PROSECUTORS ARE AWARE
OF THAT AND WILL TRY TO DISPOSE.
THESE QUESTIONS AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE.
>> SENATOR GRAHAM'S ATTORNEYS
HAVE SAID THE DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
INFORMED THEM, HE WAS SIMPLY A
WITNESS.
DID US THAT PRECLUDE HIM?
>> IT DOESN'T PRECLUDE HIM IF HE
GETS INTO AREAS WHERE HE MIGHT
BE IN TROUBLE AND I THINK THERE
MIGHT BE SOME AREAS WHERE HE
COULD HAVE SOME TROUBLE.
THE COURT NOTED THAT HE HAD
CAJOLED OFFICIALS DOWN THERE AND
THAT MAY BE MISCONDUCT.
SO HE'LL BE KIND OF TRYING TO
STEP AROUND THOSE AREAS AND STAY
OUT OF THEM.
AND IF IT GETS A DIRECT
QUESTION, HE WOULD HAVE TO TAKE
THE FIFTH.
BUT THAT'S A DISASTER FOR THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE, WHICH HE HOPES TO BE
SOON.
>> WHEN IT COMES TO, I MEAN,
WHAT IS THE MOST INFORMATION THE
FULTON COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY
WOULD LIKE TO ELICIT FROM HIM?
>> WELL, LET'S REMEMBER.
LINDSEY GRAHAM IS NOT A SENATOR
FROM GEORGIA.
HE'S FROM ANOTHER STATE, SOUTH
CAROLINA.
HE WAS IN COORDINATION WITH
TRUMP AND THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
I THINK THEY'LL LOOK THERE AND